[Music]  Paris Hilton has the best tweet we've  seen maybe ever it's a surprise  remember this viral throwback of Hilton  Lindsey Lohan and Britney Spears during  the girls trip at lilo crash she just  like chased us to the car and got in she  wasn't invited  well the throwback photo has resurfaced  on Twitter thanks to the latest Avengers  means on friday paris tweeted marvel  infinity war is the most ambitious  crossover event in history meet placing  the iconic pic of the trio crammed in a  car in 2006 while hilton isn't the first  star to get in on the funny superhero  mean Kelly Clarkson retweeted a fan who  used this pic of Jennifer Hudson Miley  Cyrus Adele Leona Lewis and Jordin  Sparks with the same caption the singer  Road you win for best tweet today look  at all that female power y'all although  I'm very stoked about infinity war fun  isn't something one considers and  balancing  but this does put a smile on my face  [Music]